hello welcome back to new rockstars
debrief I'm Erik Bosse and joining me
today are sam basher hello Maude Garrett
that's my name and our very special
guest Yolanda Machado she's a film
critic and pop culture writer for
outlets like the rap and Vice welcome
thank you great to have you today we're
gonna be talking about the stranger
things season 3 trailer we're also gonna
talk about the new Toy Story 4 trailer
some possibly fake footage for Avengers
trailers and a new Game of Thrones
poster in which the Iron Throne comes to
life what does it does it also don't
forget that you can check our goal over
to our iTunes or the Himalaya app and
listen to this episode in the form of a
podcast and if you do stop by please
rate and review us we're actually trying
to climb the podcast charts we've been
doing a pretty good job you bet where we
that's only 14 or 9 away from number one
we want a band guys we gotta beat
Ellen's we got you talking about not in
game yeah that much yeah this is dancin
I don't know how you can see you're
dancin on the podcast we don't need to
get personal here only thing we need to
get personal about is this stranger
things trailer that's a segue forced
okay so this trailer drop this week it's
for season three if you remember see
someone took place around Thanksgiving
Christmas season two took place around
Halloween so this season happens around
the fourth of July we got a good
old-fashioned 80 summer folks the
trailer opens with Dustin returning home
from summer camp it apparently is Camp
Nowhere according to his t-shirt and hat
if you look at it it looks like some
kind of nerd camp
came back and he looks like he's
erecting a weather vane or radio tower
so I don't know weather vane that's yeah
you need to yeah I was gonna make a
first joke but he's a kid now Steve has
a job at the new star Court mall which
is gonna factor into a big role in this
season Lucas has a girlfriend good for
you 11 goes to the mall now just like
Robin in How I Met Your Mother
she goes to the mall but now
for us fans of the show dancer are still
roughly the same they're still monsters
in this unluckiest Midwestern town of
Hawkins Indiana plus a great 80s
soundtrack there's two songs in this
trailer there's Motley Crue's home sweet
home and then it blends into the who's
Baba O'Riley creating this whole idea of
like teenage wasteland fitting them with
the theme of these characters are moving
into the new teenager phase it's a gang
gonna split up are they gonna stay
together are some of them getting
girlfriends we're other ones are just
getting radio well today now 12 they
have you older than that I think you're
in big trouble
Justin's 21 now the big question people
are wondering about of course is the new
monster that shows up at the end of this
trailer it looks super Cronenberg II and
like almost like John Carpenter's The
Thing it's it's really nasty insect-like
and it's a really big leg sprawling at
the side but then it's got little
princes would you like take a Strad yes
for tremors it kind of looks like the
graboids like tongue every 80s monster
there was great rolled into one
yeah I got GU pond now there's a lot of
different theories about what this could
be it could be related Emma Gorgon it
does look like it has some kind of those
inner rows of teeth it has almost a
similar horizontal multi-armed shape as
the mine flare from season 2 which is
still alive even though it's more I
would say smokier more Lovecraftian
here's the theory that I'm going with if
you look at this trailer footage you see
some of Billy and he's the new like
sexpot Rob Lowe st. Elmo's fire he
almost hooks up with mrs. wheeler that's
all right yes yeah there's a shot of him
working as a lifeguard
because everyone the 80s and all the
rock vibes from that one
is it peppercorn I think so recording
yeah that now problematic seen the it's
this nasty bite on his army see him in
showers and it's really gross beanie
looking impact infestation infection and
there are episodes entitled the bite
that's late in the season but early in
the season there's an episode called the
missing lifeguard he's getting bitten
he's getting bitten but by whom what we
see this girl I believe she's a new
character named Heather she checks him
out before mrs. wheeler checks him out
and we see her in another shot it looks
like it's the same character getting
sucked into the upside down like in the
a sunken place kind of abyss I real
quick thank God it's not will again
connect I catch a break this season can
you just have fun and not be like
traumatizing doesn't like it raining
inside his house shorter he's been
stunted emotionally and physically for
those two seas yeah
well what we're thinking is that this
other lifeguard girl might be the bar
but this season you know the early in
the season sacrificial lamb right baby
after getting sucked in this place she
returns me hooks up with Billy infects
him with this and like bite maybe and
turns him into this infestation that
into that big nasty monster that we saw
and they could be going in to check in
on Billy at the hospital and then he
morphs into this like carpentery
Cronenberg II thing and the reason I
Jacob you see up there other than I
think Jake Busey is awesome and totally
unhinged if you look at his it looks
like it's a similar bite like kind of a
bloody bite mark there could be another
he could be another person who's
infested with this thing and that could
be the type of monster we see as opposed
to some interdimensional pretty good way
to get rid of unlockable character yeah
they're going out the worst possible way
ever it looks like yeah that's the worst
way to go no no at least you get to
terrorize and oh like that's a pretty
sick way to go inside way to go which is
just Barb's just
yeah your friend ignores you and then
you're gone brief season 2 subplot where
they try to investigate what happened
but then it just turns to be set up for
shipping at the end of the season that's
all I really was well there's like a lot
of different ways to look at this I
think the idea of characters
transforming into something else as
opposed to fighting some other external
threat is a new way that they haven't
gone yet and I think that could be a fun
thing to explore yeah see I'm not
thinking about that I'm thinking that
we've gone from the Arcadia in season 2
to vaporwave this time around and that
aesthetic is sick I'm really on board
with teens summer fighting monsters also
I mentioned tremors earlier but we're
kind of on the same trajectory what was
like big monster scary one then little
ones that ran around third one they fly
we're gonna get a flying one this one
watch that sci-fi original movie and
it's not good but I've watched it well I
think we're it mentioned them the star
Court mall the final episode of the
seasons titled battle or showdown at the
Star Court and I love the idea of like
setting this in a mall reminds me that
are you afraid of the dark episode where
they like it's in a mall but it's inside
a video game but they shot it in the
mall this an idea of like using them all
as a setting for a final battle like
almost that kind of like nerdy battle it
was perfect for the eighties there was a
really terrible 80's b-movie where it
was monster well robots got taken over
by something and they were like killing
and eating eating humans and I'm I wish
I remember what it's called as a kid and
it stayed with me friends but it's
terrible so it's definitely and I grew
up in the 80s so everything happened in
the mall if you weren't at the mall you
didn't exist is online shopping like
your favorite thing in the world now
though it's fine it's weird how we feel
sad that malls are disappearing but like
that the fact that malls were a new
thing in this in this 80's area it seems
to be a subplot of this new season we
see a bunch of protesters saying like
save Hawkins downtown like repeal them
all or something I think a lot of the
small businesses of Hawkins are worried
that they're gonna go out of business
with the creation of this new star Court
mall that's cute because their biggest
thing their protests
is the new mall a portal to like open
but I get a bigger problem yeah like I
know we can't tell you about it but it's
like this is such small potatoes like
this so doesn't matter but fine go ahead
well tested hey here's my theory on this
what if they're part of the same
conspiracy right what if the new star
Court mall is being built on the grounds
of the Hopkins energy lab also
protesting the fact that they're trying
to cover up I love that spear see by
putting a mall on top of it then we get
into some poltergeist in the Amerigo
ground I'm gonna be solely upsetting
everything happens at the mall
watch out lots of stuff happen at the
mall really excited about that you get
like that feel like a little bit more
budget like there's like it like we made
a joke where's like Oh more extras but
like the CGI like looks legit like in
season 2 it was definitely like a step
up from season 1 but with like this like
tomato exploding in a microwave monster
coming out with all this teeth coming
out of every arm it's like it's I love
it like I love this and I'm so excited
to see sorry but microwaving tomorrow is
actually really quite frightening
experimenting on them hey do you think
Billy's gonna make it out if he does go
inside out now he's done for he was a
fun one too what I think the only fun
thing about his character was with he's
mrs. wheeler in the mom and the hare
favorite thing about these though is
that we don't really have to speculate
because as soon as it's out you just
binge it in one go you know it's not
cliffhanger II that's right you just
press next yeah and we still watching
hell yeah I am Netflix I think that's
mine am I kind of concerned with these
seasons we were talking about this
before the show that like because the
Netflix model is they give you all the
content all at once you watch all eight
episodes wait weeks yeah you wait
another year and a half before the next
season comes out it took me a second I
had to like remind myself of all the
other all the characters names
especially the new ones from season two
it's like I don't I love this trailer I
think they did a really good job if it
wasn't as exciting of a trailer I don't
know if I'd be as excited for season 3
that being said though yeah
they make a really good trade
yeah I like this trailer a lot I'm a
music great editing for sure and lots of
fun Easter egg references to past
seasons he has a farrier Farrah Fawcett
hairspray that Steve told him to use for
his new hairstyles Lucas's face and on
the mixtape that he listens to at the
beginning is a it says will the wise on
it which is like a reference to his D
was very proficient in fireballs because
that's what my dandy character would do
666 damage guys trivia questions
mods gonna ask her question the loser as
always will have to join the gif of
shame society alrighty
trivia questions this time please select
your cards and pens fur to fill out your
questions in an appropriate and timely
manner thank you very much this one is
which eighties movie spawned six sequels
and a TV series alright all of our
answers are here in the buckets as
always we'll reveal the answer at the
end and see what movie or six movies
into season six movies and TV series
sequels and the TV yes sounds good okay
before we continue we wanted to give a
quick shout out to this week's sponsor
care of care of is a service that makes
and delivers personalized vitamins with
care of it's super easy to be a good boy
or girl and take your vitamins now I've
been taking mine for a while now and
it's been great they come in these
convenient little packets so you can
barely have to think about it you know
what I feel pretty great wasn't fazed at
all about whatever was just happening
now you start by taking an online quiz
where they ask you about your diet and
your goals they put together the exact
right vitamin concoction for you and
they've even got an app that lets you
track your progress and earn rewards for
remembering to take your vitamins good
for you
now so a vegan and vegetarian options
available if that's your thing take
advantage of this special offer
available through the end of March for
50% off your first month a personalized
care of vitamins
just go to take care of calm and then a
rock stars fifty again that's take care
of calm and rock stars fifty for half
off your first month
vitamins oh gosh I hate how funny I
think I am well Sam what else did we
learn this week kids cuz we have some
news this week people are revisiting
some of the Russo brothers said on a
podcast shortly after infinity war came
out and here's the full quote buckle up
we look at the trailer as a very
different experience than the movie and
I think audiences are so predictive now
that you have to be very smart about how
you craft the trailer because an
audience can watch a trailer and
basically tell you what's going to
happen in the film interesting we
consume too much content so at our
disposal are lots of different shots and
that are that aren't in the movie that
we can manipulate through CG to tell a
story that we want to tell specifically
for the purpose of the trailer and not
for the film the too long didn't read
version of this is they put fake stuff
into trailers on purpose is that because
of what outlets like but we already kind
of knew this because of who we are of
course and it probably did too with the
shot of the Hulk running an infinity war
[Music]
the reason we're all talking about this
now is because people are starting to
wonder which shots from the Avengers end
game trailers are fake one popular
theory is the shot of Tony wearing the
white and red suit with his peeps he's
hanging out with him he's walking
through the terminal doing a little
catwalk what do you guys think other
ideas dead dead during this scene put
him in there so that you wouldn't be
like why is he missing if you got a
Robert Downey jr. gets you in seats yeah
you have to show him his space is always
the biggest on the poster bigger but you
just have half a profile man can wages
and I'm compared to roughly have a
little moment to appreciate Karen Gillan
just for a second guys like
coming good clothes well waste the parts
down okay I think I think the Russos are
full of crap and here's why you know
what they also said shortly I'm just
gonna keep plowing forward they also
said that endgame was not the title of
the movie in June wince when some
cinematographer movie put it on his
online resume I worked on Avengers in
gamer who's all had freaked out we did a
video about it and then they said oh no
it's not in game so yeah it's good that
they're throwing a doubt and causing
speculation we don't want anything
confirmed for sure we know things are
already happening after this movie so
let's try and you know enjoy this as
much as we can yeah I like that they're
being cagey if they need to show some
stuff to kind of you know get people
excited tease a little bit I get it war
plates important but you know do it
constantly cuz I know the press tour for
infinity war they said anybody who's
dusted State is gonna stay dead and then
they revisited somebody asked him again
like maybe a few months ago or a year
ago I forget what but it was like a QA
and they're like oh no we don't know
who's dead I don't think so yeah words
stick to your word I think we're right
to be skeptical especially with that big
group joggin shot at the end of infinity
war trailer with Hulk's in hulk form and
what kind of running there are some
theories so that could be a shot in
avengers endgame and they put it in them
at the same time but they keep using the
same promotional photo of hulk have you
seen that since Ragnarok he's always
just like it's the same one that's on
the cover of Empire and it's the same
one that's on the poster of infinity war
it's the same exact pose so maybe and oh
and there was that toy of the whole
bursting out of the Hulkbuster suit
poking out of it I never had well
speaking of toys maniacs
they have said that like 99% of what you
see in toys are wrong because they were
asked about the white armor and then
sure enough the next trailer that my
someone of the 1% of things that like I
think they do say these things we I mean
I they're playing this kind of like
wild goose chase with us and I think
it's fun we'll play along but like I I
don't think we're necessarily confirmed
like it takes a lot of effort and budget
to CGI and VFX everything do VFX
people's faces on things sprinkling it
yeah I mean yeah if you want to put I do
I understand what they're saying about
like treating the trailers like they're
their own separate thing because I like
movies that do that disappointing than
watching the trailer mean like well I
just saw them maybe yeah yeah bro
they're doing a very good job trying to
like hold back as much as possible and
really just kind of pull at your
heartstrings because it's 22 movies in
your did you're seeing it this is 23rd
second 20 this is 20 to 20 Captain
Marvel is 21 there you go and it's it's
just like yeah we we're invested we're
gonna do it all they have to do is just
kind of say a few key lines and we're
there I kind of like that they're
reflecting back instead of looking
forward I like that I thought that was a
smart thing to do they did do a little
bit of that for infinity war there was
one trailer that was great where it was
Thanos has his hand up he closed the
fist and it like it dinged or made a
snap or whatever and it started playing
like key moments from every trailer of
every movie leading up to it was like oh
good it's all leading to this and I'm
doing it again because you have to say
it's the end game it's literally right
but yeah I mean if anything like you saw
ant-man jump over a pencil like maybe we
can move on to a new little thing called
pitch me we haven't done one of these
for a little while but what we're doing
with pitch me is basically I'm gonna set
these guys a task and they're going to
pitch me an idea and you guys can join
in too in the comic comments so this
week we learned that the MCU movies from
phases one two and three so everything
from Iron Man to Avengers endgame it's
gonna be known collectively as the
infinity saga so today we're bringing
back pitch me and with this one I want
you guys to pitch me names for the next
phase or phases of the MCU so to give
you a little bit of inspiration and time
to think I'm gonna remind you that phase
of four is gonna start with spider-man
far from home and is going to include
Black Panther to Captain Marvel to dr.
strange to me too and guardians of the
galaxy three the Eternals movie and some
of the already announced a Disney Plus
shows will be in that as well
so we've got infinity Saga what is the
next phase with the MCU gonna be all
phases who's got one ready
I do go ahead okay well here's the idea
so the Infinity Saga refers to the
Avengers storyline that's the connective
tissue throughout phases one two and
three
it doesn't necessarily refer to
spider-man homecoming or what Doctor
Strange was well that did have an
infinity stone in it but not all the
movies connected to an infinity theme
that's just like the main thing we
remember this era as so what will we
remember the next era of Marvel as well
they're getting access to the x-men
right so I think a lot of these other
stories will will come out but they may
not tie into the existence and the
evolution of x-men into the Marvel world
and I think that's going to dominate the
the next era
I think Kevin Feige is gonna figure out
the way he wants to tell these x-men
stories get different directors maybe
focus on some different characters who
aren't mystique and played a weirdly big
role in all the Wolverines justice I
feel like in these x-men so I think the
next phase might be the X Generation or
Generation X or something with EXO
that's funny I was thinking I'm like
it's gonna be something like the new
class or the new kids because
everybody's brand-new they're
introducing more female characters more
diverse characters and I'm pretty sure
an end game we're gonna say goodbye to a
lot of our old favorites maybe just have
them appear as cameos or mentors further
so it's similar I'm not sure how much
they're gonna incorporate the x-men or
at least the x-men as we know it right
now and that'll be interesting to see
especially considering that Fox property
is Deadpool and Disney is definitely not
doing r-rated right so it's kind of wide
open but okay I feel like when moving
forward there we mentioned this in a
previous segment right I did it is that
they're 22 movies and they can trust
their audience that today you can't I
don't know if you can keep doing that
like I know it's like this is like
basically these are like oh this is a
season of a show and if you're watching
the finale we kind of expect that you've
watched enough to know
it's happening like it's not I mean I
can't really feel bad for you if you had
questions after infinity war like who's
the guy in in Africa what's that guy and
it's like that's your fault if you don't
know what that is and I feel like you
need to kind of do I like the idea of
reintroducing I like that idea and also
since we're playing with time travel a
lot when it got a lot of theories for
this movie are time travel what what I
would say is a fun enemy that you could
throw in there is kang and kang is like
a time-traveling like he's like oh like
he's lived throughout all of history
depending on which book you're reading
it also could be a lead-in to a younger
team of Avengers like The Young Avengers
which is a really cool character as well
when it comes to the name though I may
be like back in time and now no one's
gonna use that one but then you can play
the Huey Lewis song basically everything
or like the lack this would be a cool
one yeah I'm just gonna throw my head in
because if they my you know the more
guesses the more likely someone's gonna
be right so the fusion phase using sure
fusion face I feel like a form of paler
water form of hawk yes that's a fusion
that's the only fusion I can add Dragon
Ball Z fusion between good I also wonder
if because we music the Disney merger
was happening if anything's gonna happen
in Dark Phoenix later this year that has
been delayed like the reason what do you
think the comments fire up there yeah
tell me we'll be in maybe what you want
this next error to be defined by well
another new trailer came out this week
the Toy Story 4 trailer and it suggests
that this movie might have some pretty
intense deep themes for a kids movie
it gave us a better idea of the plot it
seems to like it's gonna focus on four
key a toy that Bonnie made in school and
it's made out of a spork and some arts
and crafts supplies it's gonna be voiced
by Tony Hale and the question here is
whether or not for key is in fact a toy
he doesn't define himself as a toy he's
a food somewhere yeah
use them thrown away yes disposable and
he doesn't want to be a toy and he
doesn't view himself as disposable and
in this trailer he jumps out of a moving
RV I didn't even really piece that part
together I thought he was just trying to
kill him so he's like no that's how he
wants to exist he wants to be used one
time and thrown away and get fined for
littering come on now we also see the
return of long-lost character Bo Peep
she didn't exist in Toy Story 3 we all
thought she suffered some horrible death
because there was a line or it's like
right we lost as well incinerator
probably but now she's still alive and
she's she presents a very tempting
alternative lifestyle partying it up
with a bunch of other lost toys opening
Woody's eyes that maybe don't need to be
attached to one specific human named
Andy who branded his name on your foot
maybe you can have a more free lifestyle
I like question for you guys where do
you think we're going with this so for
Keith literally asks why am i alive and
let's not forget the context of that Tim
Allen quote that we saw where he said
this is gonna blow your mind and you're
going to sob and want to jump out of a
movie an RV after no he said he could
barely say any of his lines and Tom
Hanks predicted it would be remembered
as a quote moment in film history has
this is a guy who's been in with several
moments in film history saying that Toy
Story 4 will be the one to change at all
all the toys in the theater that you
bring with you will come to life you say
you're full Christian name and their
eyes will light up yeah and you will
swap places with them they'll take over
yeah yeah they do have those creepy
little toys in the corner over there so
who knows maybe you'll John - slappy for
good for the goose bump fans out there
Yeah right Oh slappy that's not what
known as Toy Story Fork why didn't my
wasn't that today it's like the room
screen
safer yeah a lot people talk about how
they changed Andy's face and how that
freaks them out because now he actually
looks like a human as opposed to like a
PlayStation one generation here he looks
like the baby doll head with the crab
claws nightmare fuel and every single
one of the toy stories so far every
picture yeah they're almost cooked a lot
even the last one it's crazy I like I I
have my daughter's 11 now so she's grown
up with a lot of the Toy Story movies
and it she she just grabs the concept
right away so this whole like
existential thing she's been asking me
about death and life since I was like
three or four years old so I'm like yeah
this fits you keeps whispering we're all
gonna die but he just says that just he
does that cuz he knows it makes everyone
uncomfortable
he also stares a lot yeah love you
you're great you're not gonna be
watching this but it's cursing don't
watch it go to bed go to bed honestly
like it's it's an interesting concept
the idea that like we've all like we've
made toys everyone's made a toy or
they've made like the drones sling and
it means it meant a lot to them so
that's a fun idea but I almost feels
like a step too far where it's just like
it doesn't want to be alive or it
understand it grasps that it was a thing
that was inanimate that didn't have a
mean I mean I don't mean deathly hallows
you're not supposed to actually bring
anyone back from the dead because
they're never truly alive so it's like
you just don't mess with that it's that
kind of thing where it was an you know
inanimate now it's like I have this
thing in this life that I didn't ask for
but where does it where's the beginning
end for the toys that are molded and
like they're sewn clothes you know like
those are other products used to make
something else and they use like a why
well it's called Toy Story because
there's gonna be an end to this you'd
think with this story that's a story and
the Robert Kirkman never wants to end
neither does a historian the title guys
yeah I I'm still getting over the fact
that he said that we were never truly
alive in Deathly Hallows I'm gonna be
haunted by that for that by like humans
were never living so we never really die
what did I just hear dead people who
come back are never really alive that's
yeah you can't completely bring someone
back from the dead and I resumed their
normal living but you've seen that all
the way they're super excited about that
I have seen it making of resurrection
HBO has released an official poster for
the final season of Game of Thrones now
for our podcast listeners we're gonna
describe it for you it's basically the
you know the Iron Throne with all the
the swords poking out when you scroll
down it kind of fuses with the head of a
dress all in one encompassing it's
basically the most important things Game
of Thrones together yeah so guys tell us
does it say anything about the final
season does it suggest it a Targaryen
will sit on the Iron Throne or is it
that the throne isn't very comfortable
like dragon skills that do they don't
look comfortable to ride as the throne
doesn't look comfortable to sit in
there's you know it means if you've got
the Dragons you have the throne come on
guys it's it's a throne in the of itself
the back of a dragon
that's I'd take that over a stupid
throne in the South hey we talked about
a theory last episode or two weeks ago
that's the idea that the night King
might divide his army he'll go south to
King's Landing convert all the golden
company and march north with the power
of the iron throne and his new Queen
Cersei an attack the the forces of men
up in the north so maybe that's what
they're saying here this even though
it's got red eyes not blue this could be
meaning a dragon is coming from the same
place the Iron Throne is hey I'm
reaching yeah what I'm grasping because
he now has a dragon just setting the
dragon by itself I'll be back in two
days with everyone dead right that's
pretty cool yeah yeah I'm you were
making a comment about the number of
swords though oh yeah like the scales
the little spikes that are sticking up
from the dragon there's actually seven
at the very top which represent the
Seven Kingdoms I think kingdoms the the
light of the seven
yeah the father the mother then is a
warrior Smith Rachel yeah right there's
a stranger who's always a stranger
things that happened yeah it goes from
set and they look like swords so maybe
and then at the bottom you see two that
are very much swords I this is Owen
Daenerys okay there they're definitely
house symbols one of them it looks like
a cross the other one is that crossing
the other one looks like a like a flower
being blue I'm not well-versed in my
house sigil but yeah this throne was
forged by Aegon the conquerer he forged
it when he created the Westeros as a
nation I've seen all Seven Kingdoms they
described that in season three of the
show and it's um Varys who tells the
story and it's Petyr Baelish she says it
that's actually quite embellished and
it's a bit of a lie it's not mm I'll
just fail even 200-some is rewatching is
good I'm paying attention to that's one
of the best scenes of the show the two
of them the chaos is a lot of yes except
I don't like Petyr Baelish Oh
buckle up kids cuz we're hearing that
black Adam the DC character that the
rock has been in talks on the way for
ever will not appear in Shazam that's a
bummer but will instead appear in his
own movie before the Shazam sequel that
is weird but next bed and Guang confirms
his Avengers infinity war character Wong
is alive and gardening the sanctum as a
replacement sorcerer supreme
nice good Anya rumor has it the upcoming
Star Wars trilogy from Game of Thrones
showrunners Benioff and Weiss will focus
on the Old Republic and heavy Star Wars
meets Lord of the Rings violence but
also sounds pretty interesting
but also interesting Joe Russo's
daughter Ava has a secret cameo coming
up in Avengers endgame some suspect that
she may be playing hawkeye's daughter as
she's being taught how to you know
should arrows are trained whatnot but
it's unconfirmed we don't yeah I saw
coming side by side photo and I was like
that
she's a woman they say long hair but
also this week it was confirmed that
Danny DeVito was considered for the role
of detective Pikachu he even went in red
lines and they made a mistake I like
Ryan Reynolds now maybe that would have
been no that's okay that's Frank that's
Frank from It's Always Sunny oh my god
it is you don't get me wrong Brian
Reynolds voice is great but the voice of
Deadpool is not the voice I think of
with Deepika you love Frank Reynolds yes
I can't unhear Deadpool though now he's
got everything but speaking of having
everything the Disney Foxx merger is now
complete that's right Mickey Mouse and
Bart Simpson officially live right the
same Studios crazy time right now huh
yeah singularities beginning
we will be one
he's pretty interesting yeah hey x-men
are on their way right for the lightning
round yeah so we have it up on the
[Music]
prompter this Aaron
oh goodness me yeah it is lightning
round you guys tweeted questions we've
got some of them up on the screen I'm
gonna fire them at my co-host you have
to answer them as quickly and without
hesitation as possible are you ready
here we go Yolanda you are up first this
one's from Ryan Hinz 14 who said if you
could be one Disney animated character
from your childhood who would it be oh
god Bell easy just don't get Stockholm
Syndrome hey Sam
shup suit that's what I'm blaming it on
said what was the stupidest accident you
had as a child
oh I challenged them when you guys
tweeted out I was like I will say mo the
most embarrassing things I thought
dumbest accident I think the first one
that comes to my mind is that I cut my
little brother's hair with some
kindergarten scissors and then I blamed
him I got locked out of the house and
100% and it was 100% why I was gonna say
so curse word I didn't want to I said to
my pants my mom in a different car pull
into the driveway and I was like let's
do for you next you didn't get trampled
but hmm like your body is just like no I
will wait till we get back to the hotel
not that I ran out of times what I go oh
my dad anti-human jazz it says what's
your favorite nostalgic smell Jasmine's
these flowers that were the holiday
house that we use to venture out every
single Christmas and every time I smell
it it's like yay I'll have them at my
wedding if I ever get married ha kidding
I'm eloping for said what Disney
character do you think would work rest
in the Marvel Universe about your
childhood stitch stitch might work or
are the Incredibles fantastic for it
they're the same character types think
about it Sam you're up next with at
Jonesy I'm just got 86 Rescue Rangers
our tailspin Rescue Rangers
yes Rangers diamond
we're paying for this music whew good
thing for that
cheers Disney that's Eric at maraschino
Terry says tops reach Disney Channel
Original Movies oh sure we'll start with
Lizzie McGuire
it's amazing famous Jett Jackson
followed by even Stevens I would not
have been able to answer that but those
are my three series I think they all got
the original movies okay so we'll start
with brink brink was amazing Johnny
tsunami and a Zenon girl the 21st
century I've never had these Lapidus
someday duck for me says what was the
first movie you saw in the theater it
was actually a Little Mermaid and then
it was hook mine was et I was beauty in
the beats the only one I remember his
Iron Giant and I was not the first
person of what I remember I cried first
in a theater really messed me up because
I can't date a guy unless he can look
like Prince Eric anyway said at Turner
Guan says what's well what were your
favorite toys mine with the Millennium
Falcon in a truck that transformed into
a racetrack for tiny cars oh my God my
prayer machines I dunno I would say it
was a bee baby boy through and through
Stan's beanie baby boy yeah beanie
babies collect him I haven't been a
trash bag and somewhere my parents
garage there were something one day it
was a moose one and a tree frog
and tree for everyone I was a popular
meanwhile modes playing with Optimus
Prime with the cannon shooting at the
back but yet cool guys ulanda we've got
one here from original Huggy who said
first movie crush oh this one's easy
John Cusack in the incredible journey of
natty Gann it was like 1986 and I still
have a big crush on him
Tiger Lily star wants to ask all of us
what was the first video game you ever
played and were you any good at it
oh yeah I could play it I'll go click
Joe and Mac was the first one my brother
would let me play and but myself i play
pokemon red because that was the first
console that like my parents gave me
mine was the ms-dos I think in like 1990
or 91 and it was a game called nethack
and it had zero graphics you were an @
symbol and you had to like just press
your way around these dungeons and your
dog was a little lower case D anyway I
found it on emulator and I play it all
the time still mine is really all those
from like something called intelligence
or Atari and it was kind of like that
what is that um yeah I mean I was
terrible at it because I was a little
kid my older siblings had an old-school
Nintendo and that everyone had Super
Mario Brothers 3 that was yeah and I
wish I knew all that like my brother
knew all the secrets to crash them on
the white blocks need to go behind
everything because it's all a theatrical
production that's the the theory that's
the game theory on that one right the
curtains that begins with curtains just
like yeah ok now comes the time for a
15-second shout out this is where each
of us says 15 seconds to shout out plug
ramble about anything they want Sam do
you know something yeah I've been
working on a brand new project and you
can find out more about it on my Twitter
at Sam bash or wow that's super vague
but I'm gonna use my time that way two
weeks that's when it's coming out great
can I ask a question hmm
what is it it's new yep yeah that's
there welcome okay for my 15 seconds
April 5th to Fridays from now will be my
3rd ever darkest timeline comedy
showcase my dad Sam will be joining us
Sam Philip will be there to buff some
special guests maybe Nick Fury it'll be
a lot of fun check out the description
for the ticket info on shout out to me
I'm still binging Game of Thrones guys
I'm Mike halfway through see technically
four seasons of it I finish finish three
and a half seasons and OneNote for I've
finished four and a half seasons out of
out of six seven so what episode are you
on right now crap I've got one more
before the red wedding yes season six
because I didn't think I'd be able to
watch all of it in time so I started at
6 smashed it in two days and went
alright cool I'm gonna start back at 1
and that's what I'm doing but I have to
finish all of season 1 killing even that
time as well because I'm doing the red
carpet for season 2 so yeah as well so
guys yeah I don't have a life so shout
out to me because it's it's I'm
sacrificing things I did that was
Smallville but voluntarily tell you it
was not as good for $2 is great well
I've got a crazy busy month so just
follow me on twitter at sassy mama in LA
and you could [ __ ] I'm going to Pixar
for Toy Story 4 I'm gonna be doing Star
Wars Celebration covering to be doing
coverage for endgame and killing Eve and
Game of Thrones and it's a very tiring
to think about but follow me there all
right now comes the time to return to
our trivia question that we asked
earlier so as a reminder the loser as is
cited by our judges will have to draw
from the gif of shame and
have their foolishness broadcast to the
world for all of us to judge and laugh
at so mod if you could remind us that
question is which 80s movie spawned six
sequels and a TV series oh yeah first up
Eric wrote The Land Before Time 1991 I
believe I got this era toy mod said
Batman which might police academy police
academy oh you just did - did you say
part all I said I was gonna say - cuz
tremors and had a show and I had like
seven to eight sequel get one guess then
chairman are you gonna go they went back
in time they would Jamie Kennedy and
then they have another one Terminator
might be up yeah I could be wrong I have
terminated him a series Sarah Connor
Chronicles I'm there on six they did not
have six equal so I'm wrong about how
many Batman movies have there been since
the 80s
there's a few well correct answer the
correct answer is police academy who's
the farthest wrong yeah he's at least
right shout the tremors a lot in this
episode mainly from me
well I mean since put two answers and
we've never been allowed to put that's
blatantly no judge said no I know judge
said no meeting really and really no
spiritually tremors is closer to Police
Academy driving this bus running like
I'm throwing not throwing you under it
I'm driving it not my hate you you're
not the judge there yeah you just read
the question I did I felt very powerful
doing it
Batman has had answers playing to your
yard the things he's like and it
definitely started in the
forty's yeah it's not people in another
show fair enough
okay so I lose this one says men only on
it just a boy okay well those this is
what I have to do yeah you know why am i
explained I and I begin every video
buddy saying hi I'm Erik Bosse and it's
ridiculous because you know who I am
it's just like if I walked in a room
it's okay
well those nipple tassels aren't going
to spin themselves Yolanda as a winner
you're gonna read our good-byes while I
do this and so you could just read this
starting now there you go
thank you for watching or listening to
this week's episodes of new rock stars
debrief I want to thank our host Maude
Garrett at Maude Garrett Samba sure at
Samba sure and Eric Vasa II a vos and
special guest
Yolanda Machado sassy mama in LA
remember that this is available in audio
and video form videos at youtube.com
slash new rock stars and you can get the
audio anywhere you get your podcast use
the Himalaya app you can actually leave
comments on the podcast and it supports
the show directly comment and tweet us
at new rock stars like this video or
podcast share it around and subscribe to
rock stars for deep dives into the stuff
you love see you next week maybe not me
[Music]